foreign
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studios this is the
Ramsey Show it's where we talk with you
about your life your money your work and
your relationships
I'm Ken Kola joined by George Campbell
it's been a great week so far on Monday
David Christina talked about student
loan forgiveness and so much more George
and Dave on Tuesday talked about the FTX
collapse oh boy Warren Buffett
his comments on bitcoin and all the
things and then I Told You So from Dave
and then George and Christina talked
about a debit card with rewards Rachel
and Dave yesterday took on an
interfering mother-in-law trying to do a
budget for her son a pregnant wife whose
husband refuses to buy her soap and in
general this week we've taken calls on
buying a house investing tackling debt
buyers remorse and we even had a theme
hour on how millionaires built their
wealth it's been a great week we've got
a lot done and we're continuing to keep
going uh today as George and I take on
your money calls and your work calls
anything work related one quick point of
clarification the husband refused to buy
her soup what did I say I was wondering
you said soap and I was like either way
it's such a hilarious weird story I'll
be honest with you folks the talking
points were a little overwhelming and I
was trying to get through them quickly
for your listening pleasure and uh it
came out so I don't know what's worse
Super Soap well I thought it was
actually more provocative if the husband
wouldn't buy his wife soap now there's a
difference
I would have left it alone for the
viewing and listening audience James I
heard James needed to bring this up but
anyway if you enjoy the show uh we'd
love for you to share it subscribe leave
a review but more importantly just share
it with a friend and uh George and I are
here today to combine money calls work
calls so specifically you understand the
money calls if you're new to me and the
area of work Focus pretty simple if
you're not where you want to be spend
more time at work than you do anything
else and your income is directly related
to how much you enjoy your work how good
you're doing it so if you're stuck
I need a breakthrough you want to move
up the ladder can I do all this while in
the baby steps the answer is yes so I'm
here to take some of those work calls so
let's get to this George now that we
have uh sorted out the soup soap soup
soap uh but boy that I I think I'd keep
that at the same can you imagine a
pregnant wife and the husband won't buy
her soap
I mean hygiene or food either one is a
bad situation yeah yeah well let me tell
you something I Remember When Stacy was
pregnant I got her whatever she wanted
if she wanted a giant jar of pickles I
was on my way uh happy wife happy life
those hormones and those taste buds it's
like It's a Wonderful Life yeah the moon
I'll bring down the moon you get them
what they want Jordan marriage advice
for everybody all right let's get to the
phone Stephen is on the line at
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania Stephen how can
we help
hey guys thanks for taking my call you
bet what's up well hey guys I got a
career question kind of in a weird place
so I actually I love the job that I have
right now like I am super valued I'm
thankful for the people that I work with
I feel fulfilled with the will uh feel
fulfilled that the work that I'm doing
if I had to pick out one thing you know
it would be I wish I made a little bit
more money okay and you know I actually
had a job interview today and it is for
a little bit more but I just have
trouble leaving the job that I'm
enjoying so much but also at the same
point you know only being 30 I'm early
in my career and I just feel like I need
to be ambitious towards salary so I just
don't know what to do okay this is a
really fun question I I like this let's
focus on what you're doing now that you
really enjoy what is the work
so I'm an archivist for a large company
that dates back with a you know a rich
history with this country okay great and
and you love the current work and and my
guess is you also like the team the
people I mean it's a good healthy
environment Beyond just enjoying the
work correct yeah so you know first off
with the work you know it's history rich
as I mentioned so I really enjoyed
digging into that but then also the team
that I'm with I mean you know it just
seems like every day to thank me for the
work that I'm doing how long have you
been there how much I'm appreciated
about eight years how long
eight years okay so what's the ladder
look like in this type of work
what's up the ladder for a guy like you
knowing what you love what what is a if
you were to continually get promoted
what would that look like
unfortunately I don't really think there
is one so the company I'm with I can
absolutely promote but not within like
the same area what I'm doing right
there's actually you know with my job
I'm the only one in the country and you
know one archivist for this company
right so what do you love about this
department do you love the work with
history around history for history
or do you like the detailed nature and
the specific nature of being an
archivist which is most important to you
I'd say probably the history so now we
have a ladder my friend
you are you have hit your lid with this
organization in this particular job but
you have not hit your lid with the
organization if we open ourselves up to
other jobs is that what I'm
understanding
uh probably I don't know you know how
many jobs they would have as far as
their history goes but you know it's
worth exploring that's next up
that's my advice
before we take the the other job
opportunity I know you just interviewed
today so it's not in front of you but
before we consider leaving let's look
where we are because of the way they
treat you it is really really really
important that you're in a healthy
environment where people care about you
they're willing to develop you and then
they're willing to promote you
and what we got to find out right now is
the promotion piece are there jobs
within the company whether they're
listed as open or not are there jobs
that if they were open you would be
interested in
and and would it be fulfilling to you
and I'm going to give you my assessment
the get clear assessment it's a
20-minute assessment and essentially it
will spit out a purpose statement for
you as well as a detailed report on
Talent what you do best passion work you
love and Mission what motivates Stephen
so I'm going to give that to you as a
confirmation of what you love about what
you're doing now and then what other
jobs would be a good fit for you so next
steps where could I go where would I
want to go in my current company
then we start looking outside and we
don't just move for a larger salary
but we say where can I make more money
and do the kind of work that I really
love you've got to see what's out there
make sense
it does yeah but don't just take a job
for the larger salary because you're in
your 30s and you go I should be making
more money I should be more ambitious
because here's what will happen uh we're
seeing a tremendous amount of workers
right now that are regretting it's
called the Great regret they're
regretting leaving their job for more
money
and so-called better benefits and the
grass was not greener and that's what
you don't want to do you want to talk
about feeling stuck is making a move and
making this huge transition out of some
place that you love being and then you
get there and you go ugh because I can
tell you this George the paycheck wears
off well people call your show on the
other side of this they went kind of
took the job for more money and now
miserable should I take a pay cut for
the job that I love right which is
exactly where he finds himself and you
always say well it's not an either or
you can do both yeah well you study
money stuff and money habits all the
time
we humans quickly get over a fatter
paycheck don't we oh yeah how quickly do
we spend it and adjust our lives to that
lifestyle creep that's what there's a
name for it right because at Human
Nature is well I have more money I
should spend more money so now you got
the lifestyle creep and so you've so now
the the the the excitement over the
bigger paycheck is gone and then you're
working with real creeps so you got
lifestyle creep and you're working with
creeps oh that's good it's a whole lot
of creep going on George that's a whole
different scenario well that's what's
gonna happen if you go well I feel like
I need to be here wait wait it's okay to
feel like you want to make more money
and you can make more money and
really enjoy the work you're doing you
got to be patient though both and hang
on the line Stephen we're gonna get you
the get clear assessment for the rest of
you that need that clarity
you can get it at ramseysolutions.com
the get clear assessment go we'll be
right back with more of your calls
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey show where we
talk about your life with you we'll give
you a clear path to breakthrough and
transformation so that you can win in
your money in your work and in your
relationships I'm Ken Coleman joined by
my colleague George Campbell we're both
rocking the denim today by the way so
much denim you've got the dark denim and
I've got the uh I don't even know what
you call it but they're medium denim
medium denim Andrea is up next in
Greenville South Carolina Andrea or
Andrea which is it
and Sandra all right I guessed right
that's very exciting my call what's up
um so for the last year I have been
wanting to embark on a debt-free journey
and I finally think I have my husband
um ready to do this with me but my
ultimate question is the vehicles
um we have two vehicles that we owe
money on and do we start with one
vehicle that we trade in or do we do
both at the same time now when you say
trade in are you looking to get a
different vehicle at the same time
through the same dealership or what well
I guess ultimately trying to to get rid
of that debt um you know when I'm trying
to eliminate we have three three debts
right now of course student loan is
getting ready to start back for me and I
know that we own that together but we
just really made some crappy decisions
with vehicles I feel like and we have
very nice vehicles but it's just a lot
of depth so walk us through what the
loans are on these cars and what the
cars are worth
okay so we have the two car loans my
husband has a truck
um we still owe about uh twenty six
thousand dollars on the truck
um I have a vehicle this main family
vehicle
um SUV and we owe 33 000 on that
um then couple that with the student
loans
um that I have
um that's about forty five thousand so
that's just a huge number to me and I I
just want to do what I can to set us up
for the future well that's a great first
step the fact that you guys are willing
to sell the cars to get out of this
tells me that you've had your I've had
it moment where you drew the Line in the
Sand you said no more debt no more games
we're ready to be free
so do you know what the cars are worth
have you done your homework on that end
or for e
that's what 10 000 or so
equity in that and then the truck and
then I I yeah the truck I would think he
the same I mean again they're both new
vehicles yeah 43 for the truck within
the last year
um no I could probably get about we
could probably get about 30 for the
truck okay so you'd probably make around
four on that one that would leave you
yeah with no cars and fourteen thousand
dollars and now you got to turn around
and go buy two cars for fourteen
thousand dollars
I guess or do we do one at a time yeah
well you can do both at once obviously
you got to make sure you have a car at
any given moment
um but I would not do a trade-in for
these because you're going to get much
better value if you sell them outright
because with a trade-in you're trading
it in for another vehicle
at the same time so those dealerships
aren't going to give you as much you can
see but a lot of these dealerships
you're not going to find good deals
you're probably going to need to go
over to AutoTrader Facebook Marketplace
Craigslist to find a car that is you
know six thousand dollars seven thousand
dollar SUV and truck and they're not
gonna be pretty let me warn you right
now they're not going to be these
beautiful vehicles that you're driving
so get the picture out of your head that
it's going to have the leather heated
seats and uh and have no denser scrapes
in it
okay well I'm going to record that for
my husband uh-oh yeah what I I this is
what I want to know I mean you said at
the start of the call that I've almost
got him you know kind of he's almost
there and then we're about ready to hit
him with he's got to sell his truck and
boy is he gonna recoil on that that's
gut wrenching for me am I right yeah
it's been brought up already I can get I
can get this car oh yeah yeah I mean we
we've discussed it and he says that you
know oh I'll just get a car it'll be
better gas mileage for me going to work
anyways but then the cars he keeps
showing me are twenty and thirty
thousand dollar cars boy what is your
household income
um it's 150 a year okay what if George
and I I'm just you know let's just see
here what if
I wish he would lead
I really do he needs to man up and leave
yeah but he's not there yet what if
Andrea sells hers all right and she
pockets 10. all right and she goes and
gets a ten thousand dollar minivan or
SUV or something like that
and she puts him in the corner where
she's like you haven't manned up so I
may end up for you and I don't mean to
be ugly about it but you know like come
on he sees her she's willing to see
where her mouth is yeah and then Andrew
now you're gonna look I'm just telling
you how convinced I am
babe I'm doing this I did it you can do
it too now he has two options there
all right he you guys save up he sells
it you know and maybe he gets a ten
thousand dollar car so he has to hold on
to it or he gets really serious about
paying the the current truck off that's
the other option and so that's what I
wanted to let you know Andrea is looking
at the numbers you know we say the total
of all of your vehicles anything with a
motor in it shouldn't add up to more
than half of your income and right now
those cars are butting up right against
the line and it makes me uncomfortable
and I I like the the LeapFrog going hey
we can clean this up so much faster and
instead of a two-year Journey this could
be a one-year journey and so I love that
for you guys if that's the vision you
have but we say if you can pay it off
within two years it's okay to keep it if
it's within those parameters and making
150 you guys could pay off this debt in
two years but I think one of you should
sell the car and have that level of
sacrifice I wish it was him I don't know
that we can get him there uh just
through a phone call what's the payment
on your SUV on yours Andrea
um it is about that it's probably 650 a
month yeah so keep in mind that you not
only are you selling it and you're gonna
go buy a ten thousand dollar SUV that's
650 a month goes towards paying off his
truck that might get him think about
that yeah which that would be your next
smallest debt now are the student loans
split up are they a bunch of smaller
ones no no I actually Consolidated
they're all mine
um for my when I went back and got my
doctorate degree right before coven okay
so it's one forty five thousand dollar
day yeah it is one forty five thousand
dollar debt all right well let's I like
this plan so far is at least selling
your SUV using the 650 towards the truck
and by the way there's going to be other
sacrifices in your budget you guys need
to make and it means hey you're not
going to eat out sorry hubby right now
we're focused we're making food at home
uh we're cutting subscriptions we're
cutting all the luxuries right now
because right now we are not living in
luxury we're living in stress and if
you're taking taking on the burden of
that stress and he doesn't feel it you
need to sit down and have a real honest
conversation
and say I'm not okay I'm not doing well
and we're in this together I need you to
have just as much skin in the game I
speaking of skin in the game Andrea I
want to know is he willing to work a
part-time job or sell a bunch of stuff
is he have you had that part of the
conversation if he gets to keep his
truck then this is what he has to do
have you guys talked about that and can
he do that to add more to the 600 plus
that your SUV payment is now going to be
applied to that truck can he do more
there
we have not discussed that that needs to
be discussed I think more discussion all
around is going to be good for you I
wish he was on the phone right now I'd
be guilting him into all kinds of stuff
he needs to be selling stuff working
because here's where I'm going George
I'd like to see how much we could juice
the 600 plus car payment that we're
gonna put towards the truck that's
coming off of her SUV what if we got to
a thousand bucks 1200 bucks a month
towards the truck and then six eight ten
months from now now he can sell that
truck
pocket enough to be able to you know
what I mean like or just pay the thing
off really fast and keep the truck I
want to try to motivate him by keeping
the truck but he's got to pay it off
fast
how how quickly you think you could pay
off twenty six thousand if you freed up
that payment you guys got intense
I mean I think
less than six months
um
yeah I think we could oh I think that's
our carrot we're gonna dangle that in
front of hubs you get to keep the truck
yes that's a good one you get to keep
the truck but uh you got to pay it off
and Andrea I'm gonna gift you Financial
Peace University and see if he'll go
through this with you watch all nine
lessons together don't do this on your
own any longer and uh we're gonna give
that to you if you can convince him to
actually sit there and watch it with you
yeah
[Applause]
for calling in and being honest with us
uh better days are ahead and I tell you
what else is ahead George what's that
more of America's calls I should have
known more breakthrough more
transformation because there's more of
the Ramsey show coming up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
helping you get unstuck and become
Unstoppable this is the Ramsay show I'm
kid Coleman joined by George Campbell
we're here to answer your questions
about your life your money your work
your relationships they're all
intertwined and we want to give you some
practical steps so that you have hope
and then that you have a clear path
forward for that transformation that you
desire Orange County California one of
my favorite places George no bucks
beautiful over there no bugs out there
didn't realize that yeah I mean that's
probably not completely accurate but I
don't ever remember sitting outside ever
feeling like there were gnats and
mosquitoes you know like we have here it
could be a Tennessee problem yeah I like
it Tom is there in Orange County Tom how
can we help
hey there how's it going good How can we
help Tom
Joel I'm trying to figure out once I
have the financial means to buy a house
should I go right into doing that
because I'm kind of sick of of painting
right out here and I'm trying to figure
out if I don't buy a house where I
should invest and kind of what the next
next best move is
okay so you're saying when I have the
money is it wise to buy a house or
should I just keep renting even if I
have the money to purchase
yeah or how much money should I have
additionally compared to what I have to
put down for the house for savings and
for other things like that for security
and everything kind of the the new new
levels new Devils of home ownership and
all the things that go along with that
exactly yep so how much do you have
saved right now
um 100 000 awesome do you have any uh
debt
uh nope and you have an emergency fund
on top of the hundred or does that
include everything you have
I have that and then I have 30 000 in an
IRA in an IRA
yep okay so that's retirement so we're
not going to count that we're not going
to touch any retirement funds and how
old are you
uh 25. 25 way to go what's your
household income
uh 300 000. wow
all right this is uh this is all looking
good to me so far Tom so have you
started looking at the prices of homes
that you'd want to buy
something reasonable yep so so it would
be
six layers of other things so I live
with my girlfriend
and so we could together we have two
hundred thousand dollars oh boy so we're
trying to figure out
do we keep running do we do you get
married first do we buy a house just
rent out in California so outrageous but
it just seems like it makes sense
to buy
um I I want to jump in here I want to
jump in here Joe can is jumping in yeah
George is all over the money stuff but
what does the Wii look like what's I
mean like were you planning to to put a
ring on it and marry this gal or or is
it just kind of well yeah so that's the
that's the plan
um when we're not engaged or anything
yet so the marriage would have come a
couple years is this a one-year plan or
is it a Five-Year Plan what are you
thinking
I would say we're married in two to
three years
what's behind that what's behind the two
to three years
I think just kind of the the planning of
the wedding and kind of just getting
everything together and oh you're living
together now super busy right now and
you guys live together now
correct yep but it's going to take two
to three years to get married
um I mean could be sooner if we if we
want to I mean life's just really busy
right now some it could be
uh ideally yeah that's what I think it
will be yeah I'm gonna challenge how
busy you are I got three kids you don't
even know what busy is
okay I don't even want to hear it all
right I'll say that with all love all
right George cranky old man is done I
think he needs to be committing let's
commit let's let's get married combine
those budgets George yes combine those
numbers I'm with Ken on this I don't
think definitely do not buy a house
together that is a terrible terrible
plan that will end in heartache for a
lot of people and financial turmoil so
if you are going to get married uh then
sure once you're married buy a house
together but if you're saying hey I'm
gonna buy a house I don't know that
you're ready in the next year to buy a
house because I'm assuming Orange County
home prices are you're talking what 850
for a starter home
yeah the median's at 9 50 right now okay
and so you're looking at now you don't
need that you could buy a condo right
what do condos go for
yeah you're probably still looking at
maybe 650 to 850 in that range maybe a
little less okay so once we figure out
here's what I'm aiming for and if you
want the single family that's fine but
it may take an extra two three years to
save up for that with a down payment and
so we've got a great calculator over at
ramseysolutions.com that you can use the
mortgage calculator where you pop in the
home value you pop in your down payment
and I want you to do this on a 15-year
fixed rate mortgage because your life is
too precious and life is too short to
have a mortgage hanging around your neck
for 30 years and so with a 15-year
mortgage it's paid off in 15 years worst
case scenario and I want that payment to
be no more than a quarter of your
take-home pay so what is your take-home
pay now just after taxes before any
other deductions
um after taxes so it's a little
confusing just because it's sales and so
our paycheck's a little bit different
um
maybe between 10 and 20 000 so it's kind
of a kind of a wide range okay so you'd
be looking let's take the you know the
average whatever your tax returns were
and go right that's going to be I'm
going to divide that by 12 and then
divide that by four again to get my 25
percent of uh the take home pain number
and that kind of starts to give you a
picture of all right I need this payment
to be three thousand dollars Max and
then that dictates here's how much down
payment I need to have in order to make
this very reasonable because your life
you know you have other things in your
life too other than your house payment
you want to live you want to go on
vacation you're going to need to upgrade
the car there's Home Maintenance costs
and once you're married the income is
going to go up right
yep so I like the plan of continuing to
save up let's see you know make it some
aggressive goals can I save up a hundred
thousand dollars in the next 12 months
150 and then when you guys are married
man now we're making how much does she
make
uh 90. so it'd be 390. so now we're
making close to 400 Grand which changes
the numbers of what we could afford as
far as housing goes and maybe she saved
up some money because she was living the
debt-free lifestyle and now we've got
now we can get the single family home
six months after we're married and that
changes the picture so then with the
with the condo you would
would you say sell that or then you you
would just keep
you could upgrade that and rent that
upgrade later but again I don't want to
rush into any of this stuff with a
hundred grand and you're still going to
have to go spend 600 000 on a mortgage
that's a lot of your world uh tied up
right now especially when you might be
saving up for the engagement ring and
the wedding and other life expenses uh
so I would just use that as a filter for
example me and my wife we bought a town
home because we didn't want to wait
another five years to save up a single
family home in the Nashville area and so
we were okay with that
and that helped us to get into a home
faster
in the meantime where would you where
would you invest the hundred thousand
dollars or additional money that I saved
I would park that in a high yield
savings account for now you'll get about
three percent which I know is like well
I could do better in the market yeah
well the market if you've been paying
attention also has not been doing so hot
up until about four seconds ago and so I
don't want you losing this money with a
short time Horizon which is what you
have ahead of you you know you said hey
two to three years I'm probably looking
at buying a house getting married so I
don't want it in a riskier investment in
the market where you might be down 20
grand when you go to make that purchase
does that make sense yeah I'm definitely
feeling feeling a little bit upset right
now yeah you don't want that anxiety of
trying to time time the market
yeah
okay yeah I appreciate it yeah and I
want you to talk to uh your girlfriend
and find out what kind of wedding she's
won and and all I'm dead serious I would
be finding out like what is her vision
for a wedding does it really need to be
two to three years
um because I I you listen you I want you
I have a little extra homework
assignment for you Tom I want you to go
look up the value the health value the
financial value of being married uh the
benefits of being married are are so
transformational when people realize if
you just look at the data you know and
you're not just talking about a tax
benefit no no no no I'm saying like
they're happier they they make better
money they're healthier
um and you guys are already living
together you're playing house let's make
it official man and and go get that
house that's what I think yeah that's a
good word but you know I'm not trying to
force that on anybody no I'm just saying
forget your religious views for a moment
just look at the socioeconomic the
health the financial all that it's
There's real benefit in being married
there was a recent study that showed
married couples are way more likely to
build real wealth oh there you go so
more data just one more something to
think about I don't know
Plus
plus it's just better it's better having
a relationship all right hey we're just
getting started more calls people are
lining up don't move the Ramsey show is
right around the corner
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague
George Campbell and we are here for you
the phone number to jump in is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
it is a free call that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five
Columbus Ohio is where we're going to go
next Christina is there Christina how
can we help
um hi I'm wondering today
um if me and my husband should sell our
truck so it's worth 30 to 33 000 and we
make 75k a year so we're right at that
half of our yearly income you guys just
have one vehicle
um we have the truck and then my husband
drives a
um a car that's only worth about like
two thousand dollars okay is that the
kind of just beater to get around
so what do you drive yeah
I'm driving the truck right now oh okay
how much do you owe on the truck
um the truck is paid off oh wow so what
is selling the truck going to do for you
well we found a truck for 20K and
um if we went through the dealership and
did a trade and we'd make 7K in profit
and so we would use that to finish up
baby steps three
okay how much further let's say you
didn't do any of this how long would it
take to get through baby step three
okay so the what you're gaining here is
five months of some sacrifice of saving
up the rest of the emergency fund
yeah and so you're losing some of the
luxuries of a slightly nicer truck is
that right
yes yeah the truck that we looked at
would have double the amount of miles on
which is the biggest concern which could
then have repairs
yes okay yeah I'm I'm not so sold on
this
I would not I would keep hustling and
you're talking to the guys that are
always like sell the truck yeah you and
I tend to like to sell the cars we love
it but there's no payment on the truck
and so you're not freeing up any cash
flow there
um and you are gaining some time but I
don't think this is looking at the
numbers here the scenario this is
nothing's on fire here and so if you're
just at the end of the Rope going I
can't keep going with these baby I just
want to be done with baby step three
it's okay you're not doing anything
wrong but you also you're not in a place
where you have to do that
I would rather go get some side jobs
work overtime in order to speed baby
step three up sell other stuff uh versus
downgrade and truck for a slight profit
that's just one man's opinion I'm with
you actually George two-man's opinion
two two men
um
yeah I listen
that truck I'm gonna tell you something
you double the miles on the truck and
all of a sudden you're eating into that
emergency fund pretty quickly uh it
could happen that's my worry is that 7K
in profit disappears eight months from
now yeah because it needed some work
done yeah I think how would you feel
Christina if you didn't sell this truck
and well let's fast forward six more
months and you got that truck and
you've got the emergency fund fully
funded and now you realize hey we can
actually start a replacement fund for my
husband's two thousand dollar car so I'm
gonna have a nice truck we're going to
upgrade him oh and by the way we have a
fully funded emergency fund how would
that feel
that would be great um the other concern
I had with that though was to then say
his car lasts two years would be our
plan to have be able to buy like a ten
fifteen thousand dollar one then would
we would be over our half of our yearly
income well the truck is going to go
down in value as well
and you're probably going to be making
more money two years from now
that's true
yeah I think that would be a wash at
that point and it's not a legalistic
thing where it's at 51 it's not about
that it's just we don't want too much of
your world wrapped up in things that go
down in value uh which this for sure
will uh so I think you're gonna be
making more money and you're doing the
right things you can upgrade in to a
reasonable car and by then if you want
to sell the truck and get something
different when you're debt free you can
do that you can upgrade and truck and
spend less on a nicer truck whatever you
want to do the world is your oyster at
that point but as far as doing this to
accelerate the baby steps I just don't
see it I don't see it being worth it
yeah thank you so much for the call
Christina let's go now to Raleigh North
Carolina Aaron is on the line Aaron how
can we help
hey um so I just recently started
listening to the show and just trying to
figure out baby steps and just trying to
figure out uh where I'm at in those it's
a little overwhelming at first I feel
like I've got a couple different things
in each stuff and just not sure where to
go from here all right well first of all
thanks for uh listening and staying with
us and trusting us to call in so give
Georgia a rundown of what you mean by
I've got a few things in in several of
the steps paint that Financial picture
for him
so other than the mortgage we have about
27 000 in debt some of that student
loans some of that's on a car we also
have the three to six months of
expenses saved up for an emergency fund
and then we also have some investing as
well
um in a Roth IRA in Venezuela and some
mutual funds okay so you're doing a lot
of good things uh you're just doing it
all at once and so you're not feeling
the progress that you feel like you
should be making
right would that be accurate
yeah okay how much do you have in
savings liquid cash how much do you have
out there
um we have about twenty thousand okay
and how much are you investing right now
as a percentage of your income
so the only thing that we're investing
uh
currently is
okay so let's just say for a short
period of time we paused all investing
that gets you 500 a month back in your
life right
uh-huh that's six thousand a year you
have twenty thousand in the bank
and so if you're following the baby
steps what we would teach is you have a
thousand dollar in your starter
emergency fund you have that in fact you
have 19 extra and so baby step two we're
paying off all Consumer Debt using the
debt snowball so we're listing them out
smallest to largest all of our debts
paying minimum payments on everything
but the first one and attacking it with
the Vengeance and by with a Vengeance I
mean all of the money you have except
for that thousand dollar emergency fund
so now right you're 27 minus 19. what
does that go down to
eight uh eight yes and now with the
extra 500 bucks a month we're gonna be
able to pay that eight off really
quickly
right and so think about that is you're
you're completely debt free a few months
from now now we're at the point to
rebuild that emergency fund to three to
six months of expenses then we can move
back and unpause the investing and hit
play on that but now we're at a very
different place aren't we because we
freed up all of those payments so now
we're not just investing 500 bucks we
can invest a thousand bucks we can
double that
and so do you see the kind of momentum
that gets created by following the baby
steps in order
yeah for sure I think
that was one of those super scary things
it looks scary but what else is scary is
owing other people money and not
sleeping well at night and having to
make those payments every single month
of your hard-earned money to a lender
with interest right and so do the math
and what you're paying an interest do
the math on what those payments could do
if they was back in your life and all of
a sudden I go it's a lot scarier to be
in debt than to have not a lot of money
in the bank because truthfully
it's it's a false reality that you have
twenty thousand dollars in the bank when
you have 27 in debt and Aaron I've got a
question for you do you recall how long
it took to get the 20 000 in the
emergency fund
um
roughly maybe uh I don't know
um a year maybe okay so in the year it
took you to get your current savings up
to twenty thousand life was still going
on yes or no
yeah so my point is when you do it
George told you to do you're still going
to be okay there's nothing to be afraid
and you're gonna build up that 20 way
faster than a lot faster because you
have way more margin now once you're
debt free right and way more intensity
because you feel you exactly what you
just said I don't feel safe not having
the money in the bank good let that fuel
you to really be safe for the first time
to have what we call Financial Peace yep
so we're cheering you on can I give you
a gift before we go
sure okay I want to give you one year of
Financial Peace University and go watch
all nine lessons in there with that
we're gonna give you every dollar
premium our budgeting tool to help you
make a plan and I want you to call us
back when you're debt free so we can
celebrate with you
okay that's all I ask can I can I ask
one more quick question sure
so once I'm on the other side of that
debt which hopefully will be very soon
um as far as paying down a mortgage how
do you know how quickly and how that is
a Choose Your Own Adventure Aaron I want
you to do it faster than 15 years and
you'll be able to when you have no debt
in the world but be investing 15 any
extra margin beyond that you can start
throwing at the house and you'll get
there in no time following this plan
thank you Aaron for the call love when
we have new listeners call in George
good hour thanks to the guys behind the
glass for keeping us on the air and to
you America this is your show this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios this is the
Ramsey show where we talk about your
life your money your work and your
relationships with you I'm Ken Coleman
joined by George Campbell thrilled to
have you with us the phone number to
jump in is triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's Triple A
825-5225 phone lines are lighting up you
can still get in so let's go I'll be
talking to you about work related issues
we'll talk about relationship issues
we'll talk about your money of course so
let's go we go to Philadelphia
Pennsylvania Tammy is there Tammy how
can we help
hey good afternoon
um calling to see if you can help
um I have a situation that just seems to
not exactly be improving I've got an
aunt that this is the third time
um third time now just recently she's
messaged me asking for money because
they're tight on cash
um the past two times that she's asked
it's been like a thousand dollars here
and there
um
and she paid it back when she has
the first time she offered interest
second time she just paid back the full
amount
well I'm just getting to the point where
I I don't feel comfortable
how much longer do I keep doing this the
story just keeps dragging out like
doesn't seem to be
there doesn't seem to be an end to it no
there won't be either because you're a
bank for her you know she came to you
the first time I will say this I'm I'm
I'm pleasantly surprised that she's paid
you back both times that's the most
shocking part I was really surprised to
hear that but she's not going to change
her habits because she knows or at least
she believes up to this very moment that
when she gets in a tight pinch she comes
and tells you a story and she plays on
your emotions and you help her out but
the fact of the matter is this isn't
about her this is about you and your
life and you're not feeling good about
it so you know the answer is uh
Aunt Peggy or whatever her name is I'll
just call her that you know I'm not
giving you money anymore
I don't feel good about it
and I'm not going to do it
I definitely I'm not going to I feel
like this is the time that I say no to
her
but how do I do that very clearly I say
no you very quickly do it kindly but do
it firmly
yeah you don't have to be a jerk about
it okay and Tammy you you are not a jerk
you are a very nice person but Tammy
what you're actually afraid of is not
what you're gonna say it's how she's
going to react that's exactly right you
are really worried about it exactly and
that is something that is completely out
of your control and so the hardest thing
to do about this whole situation is
Letting Go the idea that you have
control of the outcome
because she could say exactly well we're
family and I can't believe you do this
to me and oh my gosh you're dead to me
now and she severs the relationship
that's really a worst case scenario
right
yep but if the entire relationship was
based on these transactions there was no
relationship to begin with
exactly well and that's
sort of how I'm feeling well Tammy
here's the deal I think here's your
choice
would you rather disappoint Aunt Peggy
or would you rather resent her
yeah I'm starting to resent her I know
I'm asking you to answer the question
this is a would you rather and it's
rather mild all right would you rather
disappoint her by saying kindly but
firmly as George said it very clearly
not going to give you money anymore
would you rather disappoint her or would
you rather resent her more than you
already resent her which the one do you
want to choose long term
yeah I'd rather discipline her that's
the choice and our friend Dr John
deloney quotes another psychologist when
he says choose guilt over resentment
every time
yeah that's that's the choice because
the resentment is a poison
the guilt we can deal with
but that resentment is going to sever
the relationship more than anything and
so it's going to be a hard conversation
we're not trying to belittle that uh you
know don't mince the words just say I'm
so sorry I can no longer provide money
for you I'd love to help you get on a
budget and give you some resources to do
that maybe you gift her The Total Money
Makeover we'll gift one to you if you
think she'll read it but if she's not
willing to deal with the underlying
behaviors then you're just an enabler in
this situation
exactly and I don't I definitely don't
want to be that so do you recommend
because this is like she's always
requested the money over text and it's
just easy transaction obviously yeah
text it um
do I text her back or do I is this like
a phone call situation do you recommend
sure I think next time she texts you you
give her a call and explain yeah
because over text there's no tone and so
it's easy to take things the wrong way
I'd much rather say I wanted to jump on
a call real quick I know you sent me the
text here's the situation that's a very
good point but I mean here's the deal
she you have to start this conversation
by saying hey this is going to be very
difficult this is not an easy thing for
me to do but I've decided you need to
use words like that so before we
actually lay it out there
she understands exactly what's going on
and if she senses any weakness she's
going to pounce I promise you that's a
great Point like Tammy you have to be
decided yeah like you have before we
even have the conversation you gotta go
it doesn't matter what she says what she
does how she reacts I am choosing this
for me and I've made the choice the
decision's been made this is all about
communicating a decision does that make
sense
yes yeah it does that's definitely and
Tammy listen to me no because you keep
there's nothing more on this because you
keep coming back you're so concerned
about what she's going to do and I get
it but here's what you need to
understand Tammy that no matter what
your aunt does or says as a result of
this you are not a bad person
okay I want you to say that right now I
am not a bad person say it
I am not a bad person all right then
believe it and George this is why
for years decades Dave and now we carry
that torch this money loaning family
members money never getting involved in
money issues it just oh it's a recipe
for disaster Thanksgiving is already
awkward enough isn't it true between
politics and sports let's not bring
money into it and go hey uh you remember
you owe me that money can't yeah and she
always gonna get it to you yeah and now
she starts avoiding you yeah oh
let's be very clear I I get Tammy you
know who knows what we didn't dig into
what the relationship is you know is it
the sister of you know whatever but you
know this idea of disappointing any
family member family family member is
very very difficult to think about
agreed but then there you're worried
about the damage they're gonna do
why are they gonna go tell the half the
side of the family
you know oh you're not gonna believe
this
you know it's just like you feel like
it's a no-win situation agreed and
there's that's not the case there's a
reason she went to to her niece she
knows other people in her life are gonna
go kick rocks and pound sand I'm not
gonna just gonna keep giving you money
but when it comes to Tammy's a very nice
person very and uh you know there's a
book out there called No More Mr Nice
Guy and it's for people who tend to be
people Pleasers and they want to make
people happy they don't want to make
people feel bad they want to be liked
and that can cause us to do things that
cause us to be resentful yeah and I'm
one of those people Pleasers recovering
have you read the book I have yeah you
like it amazing read so there you go
there's a good recommendation right
there for those of you who feel that you
know because that's a tough Bond break
you know where you feel bonded to family
or friends that you always have to say
yes oh it's tough that's one of the
hardest things but we're not trying to
belittle it but it's a it's as simple as
it sounds and as hard as it sounds yeah
really tough stuff well Tammy thank you
so much for uh calling in and trusting
us and hang in there do what's best for
you choose you in this situation and let
the chips fall where they may thanks
again for the call he is Georgetown well
I'm Ken Coleman and this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
welcome back America you are joining the
conversation here on the Ramsey Show I'm
Ken Coleman George Campbell joins me in
studio this hour we're here for you the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and I can't even believe I'm about to
say this George all right I'm nervous
Yeah Christmas Is Almost Here can you
believe it it really is I know I know we
have a fair statement we haven't even
carved the turkey yet but I mean I'm at
home last night fire going uh and what
is my 13 year old daughter watching a
Hallmark Christmas movie is the tree up
uh the tree's not up that's this weekend
though we're getting way ahead I thought
you were enabling this Behavior well
first of all uh you're newly married uh
so you know the Christmas movies is a
rite of passage the Hallmark stuff is
rite of passage for for most women and
uh it's it's fine it's a little too much
for me yeah well they're so predictable
for me I can't a little too cheesy a
little too mushy you know but we have
some lady oh there's a lady in the lobby
that's getting up and leaving that was
such a controversial statement she's
like I cannot handle any more criticism
of the Hallmark movies
Hallmark fans can well Hallmark's
wonderful there you go all right so the
point is Christmas is around the corner
and that means that our 10 sale uh is
the perfect thing for you people who
need some ideas and you need to keep it
in the budget all right ten dollar sale
it's bigger than ever uh if you want to
spread some life-changing cheer how you
like that life-changing cheers the
alliteration was Top Notch yeah that's
what it's what I do
um then you can get some amazing deals
like Dave's best seller baby steps
millionaires or if you'd like to help my
kids have a Christmas this year you can
buy my latest bestseller from paycheck
to purpose I feel like I put a little
extra emotional uh whammy you get
something and the and the Coleman kids
get Coleman's get a little something not
much because it's ten dollars you're
getting the book for ten dollars man I
worked hard on that thing uh but all of
uh all of those uh offers are there at
ramseysolutions.com including questions
for humans all these different
conversation cards they got 75 of them
now every conversation you could
possibly imagine you know questions for
humans who live in the North Pole that's
the latest so that's very exciting you
can get all of those great deals only
ten dollars the biggest ten dollar sale
we've ever had just in time for
Christmas at Ramsey
solutions.com all right Colby's up in
Huntsville Alabama Colby how can we help
hey guys great to talk to you I'm a huge
fan of the show oh thank you sir how can
we help today
so I just recently graduated from
college back in May I started my I guess
first real job so now that I've been
saving up money I am curious as to I
guess my next purchase is probably you
know three-ish years down the road is
when I want to put a down payment on a
house and right now I'm just piling
money in my savings account and I was
wondering if I should take out
everything but maybe the three to six
month expenses that I should use as my
emergency fund and then put the rest of
that in mutual fund
um
well you said three years
is that a hard deadline for you
it is not it's on it's not it probably
won't be any sooner than that but it's
not like three years I have to be out of
where I'm currently okay well our
general thoughts on putting money into
the market is it's long term which means
three years from now you're you could be
losing money and that scares me now over
the course of history we've seen in any
three year span you hopefully have
gained some but as we saw in the last
year uh the market was down I mean it
was hemorrhaging money and so My worry
is you know looking at Colby from three
years ago he puts his money in three
years ago and he looks up today and he's
lost 25 percent instead of gained eight
and so that is my worry with you
investing this into the market versus
parking this money in a high yield
savings account which the good news is
high yield savings accounts the interest
rates have come back in a big way
uh they're at about three percent right
now
so you have a guaranteed three percent
you can make on your money versus a
maybe eight or ten percent in the next
three years on average or maybe negative
10 percent return and so that is my
worry for you as you just graduated
you've got a lot of life ahead of you
um so I would personally would park that
in a high yield savings account if I
knew I was going to be purchasing a
house three years from now how much
money are we talking
so I have about
27 000 in there right now I was probably
Gonna Keep seven thousand out and then
do something else with the other twenty
thousand but okay I'd probably keep at
least 10 as the emergency fund and when
you start to add up your deductibles on
health insurance are you starting to pay
for that stuff yet on your own
yes okay uh and then car repairs you
have a reliable car right now
I do okay
yeah I'd probably take you said you got
the 27
I'd probably take 10 and keep in the
emergency fund and put 17 in the high
yield I mean you can keep the whole
thing in the high yield if you want I
like to park a little chunk of it in my
savings account attached to my checking
uh so that you don't have to wait for a
transfer to happen after getting a bind
okay yeah that sounds good but a lot of
wisdom for for a recent grad Ken I like
that well it's just a good sign you know
there's one more indicator that you know
people they kind of take shots at young
people you know the Next Generation blah
blah blah all this kind of stuff and the
fact is is there's Eagles there's
thoroughbreds in every generation he's
got more emotional maturity Than People
twice his age now the caveat is be sure
you're debt free as well I didn't we
didn't ask about that the way he was
talking it just sounded like he was dead
free oh I know yeah you're very sharp
hey real quick before we get back to the
phones we have a fun little segment
coming up we tried this last week what
are we doing George tell people really
this is a segment we have officially
coined 10 in 10. here's the idea in our
10 minute segment coming up at 2 30
central time I'm gonna go live on my
personal Instagram while we are live on
the Ramsay show that's right and we are
specifically going to answer questions
from the Instagram live chat and the
idea is a lightning round we are
answering these quickly and we have to
get to 10 questions in 10 seconds or
else James fires so 10 minutes in 10
minutes we did this last week so this
week we're doing it from George's
Instagram we did it from mine last week
so at George Campbell with a k k a m e l
at George Campbell so you need to go
follow him you need to get over there
because coming up in about 10 minutes
we're gonna go live on Instagram it's
going to be big fun you never know
what's going to happen over there on
Instagram well we did it last time we
had a lot of fun what was on your
account you have nicer people following
you oh I've got a lot of trolls
following me well but they they follow
you because you're so snarky well it's
called a hate follow oh yeah that's a
new thing among the youth well that you
need to know about oh is that what I
need to know about okay fantastic well
I'm not gonna hate you back George
Michael but he is deep neurotic issues
so that's okay also true all right let's
go to Tampa Florida where Dimitri joins
us Dimitri how can we help
hey how are you guys doing first time
caller here oh well fantastic thanks for
calling what's going on
well I'm 37
um I just paid off my house and um whoa
I know right way to go uh thank you uh
debt free and just need to know what the
next step in um building personal wealth
is wow that's a fun run George what does
he do well what's your net worth
uh net worth if I had to put a number on
it I'd say about a half million
incredible so what's the house worth
it's probably about 400 000. awesome and
you got about another 100 in investments
in cash
um I would call it um assets
okay well not
um not not Investments uh I've maxed out
my Roth for the last two years so
there's about
um currently about 11 in there
um and about another 90 in musical
equipment I'm a Pianist oh very cool
that's awesome yeah well your next steps
are simply to continue to build wealth
and give and so the way I look at it is
a really great filter to use there's
only three things you can do with money
give save and spend so I would allocate
some to giving because that will keep
your hand open which is what we want
when it comes to money because giving is
the most fun you can have with money I'd
allocate some for spending you're you're
a very driven guy and so that tells me
you probably don't spend a ton on
yourself do you do you go on fun
vacations buy more gear I travel I
travel good and then the other part is
save and invest and so continue doing
that right now you're you're heavy on
the on the on the home side as far as
your net worth goes I want to see the
investment side grow as well and so you
probably you might want to upgrade
in-house years from now and so start
saving up for that you can invest in
index funds or mutual funds for that or
put in a high yield savings account
but uh it's that simple
not much to it Ken I mean this is the
good stuff this is when you have total
freedom with your income every dollar
that comes in stays with you you tell it
what to do where to go and the world is
your oyster it's an incredible feeling
Dimitri uh this is incredible 37 37. oh
my goodness did you give him uh baby
steps millionaires we should let's give
him a copy of David go on the line
Dimitri George and I love to give away
Dave's stuff especially when he doesn't
know the recipient hang on this is the
Ramsay show thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more verse
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back America you've joined the
conversation about your life
specifically your money your work your
relationships I'm Ken Coleman joined by
George camel and this is a new segment
uh here on the Ramsey show if you're new
to us then you will be equally as new as
the Segway if you've been with us a
while this is called 10 and 10. so we
got to get to it we're going to try to
answer 10 questions uh in 10 minutes in
this segment and it's lightning round
and we're doing it on Instagram only so
if you want to head on over to George
Campbell's Instagram account we did this
last week together and it was on my
account this time it's on George
Campbell's account at George Campbell
with a k k a m e l good call and we're
live right now George hello uh take it
away we're taking only questions from
Instagram the tally Starts Now go Jordan
okay we got one from Andrea here how do
you prioritize paying off the house
versus saving for kids college when both
seem urgent oh that's an interesting one
well it depends on the kid's age if
they're about to go to college let's
focus on making sure they go to college
debt free if the kids are one year old
and you can start saving in an Esa or
529 then I'm okay putting more of that
margin onto the house so it all depends
on how old the kids are how urgent it is
how expensive the schooling is but do it
debt free
ammo step three I'm a stay-at-home mom
wanting to make extra money I teach
memory tricks to kids I teach on I'm not
going to try to endorse anything well so
she teaches on an online platform how do
I stand out okay here's how you stand
out you stand out by doing a really
really good job of helping one student
then the next student then the next
student then the next student you know
so many times the entrepreneurs people
that want to start something on the side
you're trying to go big and the only way
you go big is by being good so be good
for one two three four don't worry about
scaling it keep showing up and keep
delivering don't despise humble
beginnings by the way we're up to two
now all right Cameron asks Which single
stock or crypto should I invest in that
one is easy neither neither don't invest
in these volatile Investments stick to
the boring stuff like mutual funds index
funds your 401k your Roth IRAs do not
mess with single stocks or crypto your
life is too important uh Chris Wimmer
says what career advice do you have for
someone retiring from the military this
year after 20 your career well first of
all Chris thank you for your service to
our country you are a great American
second I want you to be looking into
your military career for collusion
Direction specifically what skills did
you acquire and deliver on in the
military in 20 years secondly what
experience that you have in the military
of 20-year career can you translate over
to the private sector a lot of people
who retire from the military George feel
like it's not transferable your skills
and experience are transferable the
final piece is what type of work did you
really love and if you didn't love any
type of work what kind of work do you
really want to do how do your skills and
experience set you up and if you need
some additional qualification go do it
but you can do it and you should again
thank you Chris beautifully said we've
got one from
tgrndkie we want to start the baby steps
but we need help with budgeting where do
we start well it's super easy Go
download the every dollar app and it
will walk you through how to set up your
budget you can do this online as well
everydollar.com your list out your
income followed by your expenses your
income minus expenses should equal zero
we call that a zero base budget and that
helps you start to figure out as you
track it do we need to make some Cuts
how do we find more margin do we need
more income that's what Ken helps you do
as well and so that's going to be a
great start message me I can send you
some resources on that as well all right
next is uh Mega
boy that's a tough one not sure if
that's phonetically correct but that's
my shot my annual review is coming up in
a few months any tips on boosting my
chances for a decent raise like that
well let me tell you this you can't help
your boss determine how much you will
get that's going to be over your head
here's what you want to do you want to
set yourself up to where you're having
an current and an ongoing conversation
about a race and we don't ask for a
raise George we ask for a growth plan it
looks like this here's the conversation
Hey listen I really like being here and
I want to continue to grow here and
specifically I'd like you as my leader
to help me develop a growth plan that
includes what are some things that I
could be doing better in my current role
two what are some skills and experience
that I could add to my tool belt to make
me more valuable and in three how do we
measure that so that I can get more
responsibility and more compensation I'd
like to let you write that out for me
let's get together on this because I
want to be held accountable because I
want to win that's how you go after the
race that's a good one all right back to
a money question from David Busby do you
count maxing out an HSA as part of the
15 that we talk about in baby step four
I Max my Roth contribute to a 401k but
would like to Max the HSA next love the
question HSA is a health savings account
and it's not part of your 15 of
investing for retirement in baby step
four because it only can be used towards
qualified medical expenses so your HVAC
goes out you need a car repair done well
you can't use your HSA and so we're not
going to count that but I love the idea
of maxing it out but only once you are
in baby step seven because the rest of
the margin you still need to pay off the
house early you need to start saving for
kids college so there's a time and place
for it but big fan of the HSA Lisa x 97
asks is it realistic to start a second
career after retiring from your first
career at 50. yes it's realistic in fact
I think it'll be a lot of fun what a fun
journey to take that first career and
the skills and experience that you've
Acquired and then put it to something
that you actually have always wanted to
do because you don't have to work now
you get to work I say go for it you
still have many chapters left to right I
love that one uh here's a fun one advice
for newlyweds with finances from Caleb
well number one getting on the same page
with money that is the foundation of all
of this if you're not on the same page
you're going different directions it's
not going to end well so number one do a
budget together and you both need to
have a say in what goes into the budget
and so one person can kind of own it but
you got to make tweaks to it the free
Spirits the Nerds need to come together
on this and number two set of vision and
set goals for both of you not just one
of you where do we want to see ourselves
five years from now we want to be out of
debt we want to have a paid for house we
want to get the down payment whatever
that is be aiming towards that together
and have fun make sure that you're both
have some fun money in the budget for
each of you to enjoy to do the things
you love to do James how many questions
are we up to so far that was nine so
yeah okay let's see the little fun one
here all right this is a very relevant
right now uh this is from Courtney 109
pumpkin pie or pecan pie George you
first pecan for me pecan for me and a
dollop of whipped cream on top just a
dollop just no more no less just a
dollar oh this is a fun one for you Ken
does maintaining a LinkedIn really
matter and yes my name is link that
comes from a guy named link oh link who
wants to know what he should do on
LinkedIn well link you should be on
LinkedIn I think it's a wonderful
wonderful tool for connection and
information but don't rely only on the
uh the messaging format from LinkedIn
because here's the deal everybody's
there for the same reason largely for
themselves nothing wrong with that
however if you just rely on the LinkedIn
messaging to connect to somebody you
might get ignored because let's be
honest everybody's busy so here's what I
want use the information from LinkedIn
to make a real life connection I know
where they work so I can figure out I
can write a handwritten note and mail it
I can call I can set up a meaning all
the good stuff so don't rely completely
on the messaging but yes you should be
there here's one from SC fishing what's
a good emergency fund amount for an
eighty thousand dollar annual income
well the way we look at emergency funds
is three to six months of expenses and
so the income isn't as relevant of a
piece of this equation and so start to
look at hey what does it take for us to
live in a single given month for our
basic expenses then we can multiply that
out and if you're if you've got risky
irregular income you're a single income
and you've got two people I would lean
it towards the six months if you got two
stable jobs uh not a lot of health
concerns then you can lean it towards
that three months and so it all comes
down to your expenses what would it take
for you to survive in a given month and
multiply that out uh real quick before
we get to our uh maybe one more question
here all you people saying it's pecan
you're wrong all right and go back to
where you were it's not pecan it's pecan
raise these people I don't know what's
happening in the world today uh Holly
Laris 28 says should I stay at a job I
hate when my husband and I are a month
away from starting the home buying
process now uh you've got two separate
questions here should you stay in the
job you hate no should you stay stay in
that job until you replace it because
you're in the home buying process yes
but do not leave the job unless you have
something to leave too you can hang in
there a little bit longer until you
replace it but don't leave it without
stepping into something else can I just
end with this one Derek Miller said Ken
is a gangster and I just want to point
out how that is categorically false not
true yeah I mean the furthest thing from
gangster there is is me keep in mind
that's what I said earlier you ever
known a gangster to use the word dollop
I don't think so also one more Braden
Wilson George he says ham or turkey what
say you sir oh I'm going ham all day
long no sir turkey get a better nap out
of that all right there it is 10 and 10
we did way more than 10. oh high fives
I'm exhausted we got to take a break
we'll be back though this is the Ramsey
Show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show America
I'm Ken Coleman joined by George camel
thrilled to have you with us the phone
number to jump in is triple eight eight
two five five two two five hey if you
have gone through Financial Peace
University chances are is because
someone else in your life lit a fire
under you or maybe Mom and Dad or
another family member gave it to you as
a gift or maybe your pastor offered it
at your church so you took the class you
started working the baby steps and now
everything's different you've changed
your future and your family tree and so
now you can give someone you care
about Financial Peace University
and give them the same hope and with
Christmas coming this is the perfect
time to do it and when you give FPU as a
gift they get more than just a course
they get the premium version of every
dollar so they can start living on a
budget so uh this Christmas you can give
the people you care about the gift that
actually matters hope and freedom to buy
FPU as a gift go to Ramsay solution
dot com slash give FPU that's
ramseysolutions.com
give
FPU good stuff there George have you
given it away as a Christmas gift before
uh I have I usually pair with something
else just so it doesn't feel like hey
you're not great with money here I'm
gonna gift it so I like the very
thoughtful with a little something yeah
well what would that be I think people
want to hear that idea now uh let me
think what I've done before
um I've done some special anti-baked
Goods well baked goods okay so uh FPU
and some goodies a heated blanket oh
very nice that's a fan favorite wow so
think of that something personalized to
them yeah very nice on top of that I
like that don't be surprised if you
don't get a uh personalized blanket from
me this year a heated person
of course hashtag bless this mess on it
uh that's perfect let's go to Whitney
who's in Philadelphia Pennsylvania
Whitney how can we help
hi gentlemen I'm so excited to talk to
the root beer float team come on that's
what America is telling us we are the
root beer by the way is George the root
beer or uh or is he the vanilla ice
cream or what do I tell us
I feel like George is the root beer
because he's bubbling fizzly and Ken
you're definitely like the smooth Rich
vanilla there it is wow the people
beautifully said wow so yeah this
analogy continues to take a life of its
own and when you call in and tell us
that we're gonna have to ask first time
I've been described as fizzy I've never
felt so good about being called vanilla
though rich as well so she really made
that feel good so that's good all right
Whitney it's all about you thank you for
calling how can we help
thanks so much okay so this is a
two-parter the first part is I just want
to say thank you to all of you and all
that you do
um you've been a blessing on our
family's life and sorry anything else
you need emotional we were able to pay
off um 250 000 of the home and credit
card debt yay Whitney guys so thank you
so much for all that you do well it's an
honor to be a part of that you guys did
the hard work we're so proud of you yeah
you did all the work whoa that's amazing
thank you thank you but um so now that
we're not working seven days a week
anymore
um we haven't been able to plug into a
church yet and we're just trying to
figure out what we should do with that
10 ties and extra giving do we just park
a new savings account do we give it to
an organization like especially with the
holiday season like we want to make sure
that we're really giving back
um all the blessings that God has given
to us but we just don't know what the
right way to how to do that is it's a
great question and I've been there when
I first moved to Nashville and you're
kind of church shopping as we call it
here which is sad but there's more
churches than people around here uh and
so what we did or what I did at the time
I was single is I found local Ministries
and some national Ministries that I
really respected I love the work they
were doing and I gave there while I was
looking around for a church
okay okay so it's okay because we have
we listen to like some church podcasts
and things like that but we weren't sure
if those should be more focused on your
local community or for the time being
it's okay to do something that's like a
wider has a wider screen yes I mean I
think scripture is pretty clear that
your local church
um is where that should go once you have
that and you could save it and do it as
a lump sum once you find the church that
could be a really cool way to bless them
but in the meantime you know number one
we gave up on Church shopping let's just
plug in somewhere you know we don't need
to find something that's to our exact
taste and I get that you know you're you
could be in between there but find
something a local Ministry especially
that you appreciate a non-profit that
has run very well that you can pour into
in this season until you plug into that
church
so I love the question I love the heart
behind it the fact that you even are
grappling with this question is amazing
and again this is not like a Salvation
issue you're not going to get dinged on
your your jewels on the crown in heaven
Ken this is not that no I mean seriously
this this comes down to this is this is
about the spirit of it and to your point
why you're you can save that tithe pull
it aside and then once you choose the
church home then you can you know uh go
ahead and and pay it there and and
that's perfectly fine there's it's not a
bunch
no no so uh but I love the question and
I also I tell you I love the emotion
uh the true gratitude that you hear from
somebody they get choked up you know uh
because they're just so grateful uh to
have arrived at a destination and in
this situation it is being debt free and
that that's all well I can tell when
he's a generous person and so once
you're debt free on top of the tithe now
you can do offerings and you can really
give outrageous that's right that's
where it gets exciting all right let's
go to Mike now in Syracuse New York Mike
how can we help
good afternoon gentlemen yeah you bet
what's happening
first-hand caller long time list oh I
love this one yeah well well on my way
to debt-free uh living uh only because
listening to you guys over the years I
appreciate it so much
um so my question is um back in my
stupid Finance time like
2005-2007 I made some really dumb
business decisions I feel
um I have one outstanding debt uh from a
company I probably shouldn't mention
um but uh so there was like a 37 000
debt balance that I that I was kind of
Wheeling with him about three years ago
uh about a year and a half ago I was
working with a company I was trying to
settle
um I was trying to pitch him like I
don't know like 18 Grand to settle on to
37 000 they denied it said and we kind
of lost contact about a year and a half
ago uh recently received a letter from
them they're willing to settle this
whole thing for like five grand this is
a business line of credit
um I am the owner the company
so I'm just I need some advice as to uh
if you were me would you follow through
and pay that five grand or just tell
them to go jump on a lake well did you
take out the amount of debt the 37. I
it's it's certainly my debt yes but yeah
as I said they hadn't contacted me they
kind of you know lost lost communication
with them uh wouldn't do the 18 now
coming back for five I guess I just need
some advice which direction to go I
would be grateful it's at five and I
would stop losing sleep over it and pay
them the five and uh move on with my
life but I would not just ignore this
and tell them to kick rocks and pound
sand I mean you took out the debt you
signed your name on the paper yeah I
think you do the thing you know have the
Integrity to just go all right it was a
long time ago I could probably ignore it
and have it go away but man I'm gonna
sleep better at night knowing I did the
right thing so you're so close man
yeah and there's nothing on my credit
report regarding this nothing they
haven't even sent you know they haven't
sent me in or anything like that oh good
and that's why I'm like you know where
I'm at right now I'm I'm more than
willing to get responsibility for it I
just said like I said I just I've never
been in this situation and uh Wanda yeah
be sure to get it in writing that this
thing is clear yeah yep
that you have no more relationship with
them that's the way to do it yeah and
there's this uh
you know I love that he's asking the
question I love that he's willing to be
transparent to go okay do I do this or
do I just say forget it man it's not on
my record the statute of limitations and
he's making a and and you know there's
just something that um it does for your
soul to settle this thing oh absolutely
yeah on one side there's the integrity
and character of you know cool I took
out the debt on the other side it really
does free you and you don't realize the
weight that these situations have in our
minds on us physically I mean it's it's
absolutely incredible once you really
look at it so it really is I'm I'm doing
it Ken getting rid of the day
uh hey you know that feeling George you
get when you finally remember to leave
your keys by the front door so the next
morning when you're running late they're
right where they're supposed to be been
there done that do you I don't think you
experienced that you seem to be very put
together uh me other than this is
written but that's part of being put
together oh very nice well here's one of
those opportunities we're heading to the
holiday season where our brains are
focused on buying presents thawing
turkeys and all of the things and then
all of a sudden it's January and we feel
behind on everything thing we want you
to make plans to start the New Year
Strong by joining us for Building Wealth
live here in Nashville January 12th oh
it's going to be great we're also headed
to Indianapolis Austin Salt Lake City in
Anaheim for our 2023 event season Dave
Ramsey Rachel Cruz myself uh George
Campbell Dr John deloney all of us
together passes are only 39 you can
reserve your seat now for a Building
Wealth live event it's
ramseysolutions.com events
ramsesolutions.com
events we'll see you on the road hey
it's been a great hour thank you George
thank you guys thank you America this is
the Ramsay show
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios this is the
Ramsey Show it's where we talk with you
about your life your money and your work
and your relationships I'm Ken Coleman
joined by George Campbell this hour
phone number for you to jump in is
toll-free and it is triple eight eight
two five five two two five eight eight
two five five two two five we'd love to
hear from you and uh just a reminder
George is here obviously anchoring your
uh money and financial questions and I'm
here to weigh in on your work life are
you stuck do you feel like you're
getting overlooked I'm not sure where
you want to go are you worried that you
won't be able to make any career moves
or changes while in the baby steps
anything work related I'm here to weigh
in on that as well I would love to take
your call so let's take your money calls
and your work calls this hour let's
start it off with Scott in Indianapolis
Indiana Scott how can we help
all right thank you guys for taking my
call I'm looking forward to seeing you
guys here in Indianapolis here in
February oh I'm glad you'll be making it
to the Building Wealth event that's
awesome absolutely I already have my
tickets
I didn't have to give them away then
there you go yeah
so I have a question about health
insurance so I I am self-employed 32
years old healthy I am in baby steps
four and six I'm hoping to be uh baby
step at seven paying off my house in the
next year and a half or so wow um uh
right now I have a health savings
account plan
um I have never used that health
insurance plan I just never go to the
doctor really
um consider yourself that is awesome
yeah uh the uh the premium right now is
325 a month I'm self-employed uh so not
often through an employer
uh but I with it being open enrollment
season I was talking to my insurance
agent a couple weeks ago and that same
policy is going to be going up to 400 a
month which is a pretty heavy uh
increase
so uh pretty much all the HSA eligible
plans are going to be around that 400 a
month range
um she also threw out another option
which is going to be an 11 000
deductible plan a no HSA eligibility but
it will be 112 a month
um this one has a fifty four hundred
dollar deductible but again I don't
really use my health insurance so it's
just for catastrophic
um I heard you guys a couple of segments
ago in the uh Instagram uh flash
questions talking about how you don't
really recommend invest using the HSA
for Investments until baby step seven
but even then once I get to baby step
seven at what point does the high
premium make it not make sense for
continuing to do HSA Investments
that is a great question because you're
saying hey I'm going to save what is
that uh 288 dollars a month
if I switch over to this other plan
which is 3 500 a year how much do you
make
um this year it's been a really good
year hoping to make over 200. oh my
goodness that's incredible well I mean
the truth of the math is that this is a
drop in the bucket for you to have an
increase of 75 making your income and it
still stinks you're like well I'm not
really using it so the question is with
the higher deductible you have that
money in the bank I assume because
you're following the baby steps so if
you needed to hit your max out of pocket
for the year you it wouldn't tank you
even going to the 11. now the part of
the HSA that I do like is that you can
use it as a great retirement tool and so
if you max out that HSA from 32 to 65
well there's a really cool rule that
once you get 65 you can actually just
use it for retirement not even towards
medical expenses so there's some really
cool aspects of the HSA that I don't
want to throw away just to go well we're
saving three grand a year when that
could mean some buku bucks with compound
growth over the next 30 years if you
invest in that so I would sit down
number one with your insurance Pro are
they shopping around different companies
are they beholden to one
uh no they're shopping around different
insurance companies but again with me
being self-employed it's kind of our
options are welled out here not as great
as through an employer yeah yeah exactly
do you think you'll be self-employed
forever
uh pretty much yes you're crushing it on
your own what do you do yeah I I'm a
chiropractor awesome nice way to go and
debt free a debt-free chiropractor we
like to hear that I was about to have a
paid for house yeah so I mean these are
these are the kind of nitpicking
questions where I would sit down and do
the math of hey if I invested in my HSA
what could that look like over 30 years
and is it worth taking the hit of the
extra you know 3 500 bucks a year I'm
paying
and we don't know what health care is
going to cost next year and 10 years
from now and 20 years from now so
there's something else to factor in as
well so as a healthy guy I hope you
continue to remain healthy and I think
the deductible is not that big of a deal
in your world and so I don't think
there's a terrible way you could go on
either side of this thing
okay yeah I like I said I've been I've
been using this as exactly like you said
investment an investment vehicle for
just letting it grow not touching that
uh HSA investment for the last couple
years but
um I was just thinking at one point if
it continues to go up and up and up with
it all of a sudden the 7 500 or 75
dollars more a month at what point do I
just have to draw a line and be like
this just doesn't make sense yeah no
that makes sense and at one point you
might be self-insured where you go all
right I can have a crazy catastrophic
plan but other than that I'm gonna be
okay if something goes down but that's a
great question Scott I mean you're
asking the right questions you could
also sit down with an investment Pro
like a smart investor Pro and crunch the
numbers on the HSA side and then you can
start to compare those numbers Apples to
Apples uh you know it's hard to do that
in a quick radio call but it really is
and uh he's coming to the Indianapolis
event I can't wait to make Scott make
sure you uh you meet us we usually hang
out after the event and do pictures and
well I was wondering if we should invite
you backstage for a pre-event adjustment
oh my goodness again that's a great idea
I don't know if we'll have to have any
kind of forms or you know x-rays ahead
of time but can't lay down in the green
room couch and just get adjusted I would
trust him a little snap crackle pop and
uh you're you're feeling good when you
head out on stage there George I love
that that's what Ken was thinking about
we're shooting the breeze on hsa's Ken's
like I could really use an adjustment
right now well you were listen this is
your lane Matt you were giving me great
advice and I'm over here going boy I
sure would like uh you know a little
neck adjustment right Scott be sure to
get in touch and if you want to join us
uh for the Building Wealth you don't
have to come to the green room and give
Ken an adjustment no if not but if you
want to I'm sure we can make it right
Ken's just letting any old Stranger In
The Green Room saying you say you're a
chiropractor that's not any old stranger
I Trust Scott with my whole life this
guy is incredible Financial shape and
and in all seriousness you know when we
talk to chiropractors or dentists or
doctors that have a practice and they're
not just swimming in debt boy it's such
a shocking part this guy's debt free and
he's gonna have but paid for a house in
a year and a half I know and a probably
a thriving business and he could grow it
as much as he would like to grow this is
the way to do it absolutely you know
versus you get a practice and you're
just you're 300 Grand in the hole for
the practice and you still have your
student loans it gives me a stomach you
know what we need to get Ken some Tums
tubs well that's right we haven't had a
Tums moment on the show in quite some
time not that we want one uh we don't
like the heartburn on the show not
sponsored by the way no not sponsored
not at all not at all all right Scott
great talking to you hopefully we'll get
to see you in Indianapolis and uh keep
on keeping on the best is yet to be he's
George Campbell I'm Ken Coleman and you
know so this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the Ramsey Show continues it continues
to give you practical wisdom that will
lead to transformation in your money
life your work life and your
relationship life I'm Ken Coleman joined
by George Campbell and we are excited to
be with you the phone number to jump in
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five that's triple eight eight two
five five two two five uh Sam joins us
in Minneapolis Minnesota now Sam how can
we help
hey
um I was calling because I am currently
on baby step four and and going to
graduate school here soon and I'm going
to be acquiring about tens of thousand
dollars of debt roughly 97 and I was
wondering when I start saving that 15
should I where should I be investing it
since I know I'm not in debt now but I
will be
so you're currently debt free but you're
soon to be in a hundred thousand dollars
of debt
yes okay so you're taking all these
loans out at once is it too late to talk
you off the ledge out of any of this you
already signed the paperwork I'm taking
out and you won't oh you haven't
no I just got accepted last week well
congratulations yeah thank you and what
are you getting your uh your doctorate
in
um I'm getting my doctor in medicine
very cool wow which way do you want to
go
um I'm actually going to South College
in Knoxville okay but I meant like which
what kind of practice what kind of
medicine are you gonna practice
um I would like to be a pharmacy
coordinator I like doing the behind the
scenes stuff to be people just go have
their visits smoothly awesome uh do you
have to have a doctorate to have that
job
oh you typically have to be a pharmacist
yeah but you don't need the doctorate
correct
um
I guess it depends on where you go okay
here's why I'm asking this we don't want
to see it go into debt so if you need
the doctorate I get it uh Georgie looked
that up do you need a doctorate is that
a requirement here I'm currently not
seeing that I did see the median salary
for pharmacy coordinators in Tennessee
is about 50 Grand which tells me there's
probably not a doctorate invite I don't
think so at that level and Sam here's
why I'm asking that again if it does
require a doctorate we want you to be
patient and save the cash up and get the
doctorate George and I were just talking
about this earlier in the show where we
had a chiropractor call in who was not
swimming in debt and as a result you
could hear him laughing he's about to
pay off his house pay it off his house
and he's enjoying his work uh so if you
don't need the doctor don't do it
and you don't have the cash anyway but
if you have to have the doctorate do it
but save up the cash and Sam as far as
the baby steps go you're kind of in the
pause phase where you're trying to cash
flow this doctorate if you are pursuing
that and so you would not be investing
anything right now your one job is to
stack up as much cash as possible in
order to go through this program
completely debt free
so once you're out of that you're on the
other side of this you know what's
happening if you have debt you don't
have debt then you can start investing
once you're debt free with that fully
funded emergency fund but right now you
got some life ahead you have some big
decisions to make and I'm so glad you
called before you signed on that dotted
line and if you need some some more
insight on this please go watch our
documentary borrow the future it is free
on YouTube now and it's about 88 minutes
long and it's going to give you some
real good perspective on higher
education student loans and this crisis
we find ourselves in
oh sure
um I guess I don't think it's a pharmacy
coordinator I just know my manager's
manager right now is a pharmacy
coordinator and he makes roughly 200
000. okay so maybe a different title or
role yeah I think you need a little more
research and and Sam I mean you do not
want to step into the hundred thousand
dollar loan if you don't need this
doctorate you do not want to do it so
let's go spend a little bit more time
researching talking to uh those actual
people there that you know on the ground
and go hey what is required to get to
where you are okay and they're going to
be willing to answer those questions but
again you need to delineate between
someone suggesting that you get a
doctorate versus needing the doctorate
do you understand what I'm saying
yes all right well thank you for the
call and again you know George back to
just in case anybody's confused if a
degree whether it be an undergrad
or a graduate level degree is the only
way to get where you want to go then yes
we want you to do it but we want you to
take the advice of Christina Ellis you
know we have a best-selling book called
debt free degree you know we want you to
pay cash for it it is not worth it you
know all too well the ugly side of the
borrowed future uh documentary and and
and and it's just it's never worth going
into that debt yeah and I stumbled
myself before I knew about Ramsey
stumbled into 36 000 worth of debt and
unfortunately you can't stumble out as
it turns out no you go into that real
nonchalantly again but you gotta be
shalant if you want to pay it off I like
what you did there is that actually a
word I don't think so but I know you're
a Wordsmith I feel like it is because if
if a word is nonchalant then then what
is shalant one would think Ken yeah
let's look that up I think a quick
Google search I think America wants to
know uh I mean because if you're if it's
non-invasive it's not coming up in the
dictionary it's invasive it is or like
I've always wondered about overwhelming
and underwhelming is something just
whelming okay all right we will tools we
will table this issue for a commercial
break and come back to you Webster's got
nothing on chalant so there it is uh
let's go to Spokane Washington Tom is on
the line Tom how can we help
hey guys I have a rental question so I I
got a new landlord in July
he said he was going to get a management
company to come and take care of
everything
uh he gave me his name I didn't sign
anything no new lease or anything uh and
then I never saw him again so I'm
sitting on six months rent haven't heard
from anybody just learned what to do
okay for six months
you've not seen or heard you've not
gotten a bill nothing is this person
alive
no that's kind of what either he's in
jail or he's
dead is this a house are you renting a
house
a duplex dude he bought two duplexes
right next to each other and he hasn't
picked up rent from anybody okay so so
this isn't just you you have other
people that are in the duplexes with you
with you and nobody's heard anything
yeah and we did the math he's over 20k
in rent that he's hasn't picked up does
he own the did he own these duplexes
outright or was he in debt for him
oh I'm not sure
well
this is very I would honestly go to
police and do a welfare check on this on
this person yeah yeah because my in-laws
are worried he's trying to pull some
kind of scam but I
know it's a weird scam to pull when
there's no money coming out of your
account yeah like you're not you're not
you're not legally liable for anything
you haven't even signed a lease
agreement
and that's the other thing he said our
rent was going to go up another 400 but
we didn't sign anything so my neighbor
is still
budgeting the old rent and not the new
rent because he doesn't sign anything do
you think I should uh go off of what he
said the increase
oh first of all you you don't point it
it's all yeah there's there's nothing
for you to do other than I guess you
could like George said file a missing
person uh or do a little research and
find out where this guy is because what
the only thing I'm concerned about I
honestly Tom you kind of I'm processing
this one if I was in your shoes first of
all I wouldn't be paying anybody
anything I haven't gotten a bill we
haven't heard from the guy definitely
yeah they don't want to spend that money
but I'm not spending it but I'm also
making plans to go somewhere else in
case this thing goes you know wacky you
know he's either going to show up at
some point and ask for the money or
something's really wrong and you're not
going to be able to squat there forever
right so I'd save the money and have a
backup well that's what we're doing I
know but you're technically not doing
anything wrong because the owner's not
existing here's the other thing I would
do I would absolutely stay there but I
would have a plan that I could get out
of there in 36 48 hours if I had to
okay yeah is there any other uh
Association tied to the the building
is there anyone else you get in touch
with
we maintenance anyone
well that's the weird thing is
somebody's still paying the water bill
the water still works all right so call
the water department like just do a
little bit of pan we need to get in
touch with them yeah I I I would do this
is a very uh simple investigation thing
here where you can call the utilities
and start nosing around and figure out
what's going on I'd be preparing to
leave something doesn't add up it's we
spooky situation spooky in Spokane
George
that's what's going on there leave it to
Ken Coleman with the alliteration I love
it I'm always here for you George hey
we're here for you don't move more of
your calls coming up this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back America you are joining the
conversation about your life here on the
Ramsey Show I'm Kim Coleman Jordan by
George camel appliance.com's 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure or pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free by
the way I did that once and
mish-measured mismeasured can't talk but
uh shock of no one exactly don't leave
that to Ken Coleman to measure the blunt
that's well it's intricate and I would
gripe about it except for
blinds.com
I called them up called the customer
service told them I was a bonehead you
know fell All Over The Sword and the
nice person was like hey don't worry
about it that's why we do this so when I
read this I want people to understand I
know
what it's like to mismeasure and they
take care of you so anyway you get free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more all you got to do is use the
promo code Ramsay to get the best deal
today's question comes from Robert in
Connecticut I currently work at a job in
the social services field making about
45 000 a year I don't hate my job but I
do want to make more money I've got a
degree in Psychology which I absolutely
despise due to the fact that I went to
college because I lacked the
self-confidence at 18 to stand up to my
parents and stand my grant oh yikes now
I'm 25 and I'm more confident than ever
I'm thinking about going back to school
for accounting because it's a lucrative
field with a lot of job security I don't
necessarily want to be an accountant but
as I get older I see there's Great Value
and a stable job on the other hand I'm
still young and want to pursue YouTube
I've got an idea for a podcast I want to
do with a friend that I'm confident is
unique it's what I'm passionate about
and hopefully it'll blow up I'm also a
realist and know that I do need to start
taking life more seriously and start
focusing on a stable career rather than
taking a chance and throwing myself into
the this podcast not knowing what the
outcome will be for certain any thoughts
yeah lots of thoughts here so many
thoughts wow okay let's just review for
everybody uh he's in Social Services
making forty five thousand a year wants
to make more money good fantastic uh
you has a degree that he has no interest
in Psychology all right now he's
thinking about accountant because
somebody somewhere or he read something
somewhere where he said oh accounting is
such a very good stable career I can
make good money
but he didn't want to do it he wants to
try the YouTube and podcasting which he
should do but they don't have to be
exclusive I it's not all in on the
podcast and YouTube It's I'm going to do
that on the side
meaning I'm going to do it nights and
weekends or early mornings and I'm going
to put out content and see if it does in
fact blow up okay but while I'm doing
that I'm actually pursuing work that I'm
good at work that I enjoy and work the
producers results that matter to me he
needs to get clear career assessment in
all honesty just to be able to go what
work was I put on this planet to do in
other words
what am I good at
what do I love to do what results matter
to me folks that is a purpose statement
for each one of us if we spend the
majority of our day using what we do
best to do work we love to produce
results that matter to us we are
experiencing purpose and meaning
and we're actually enjoying it because
we're good at it and we love the work
and so our personal life tends to be a
little bit better our financial life is
better if we're making solid decisions
because we're excelling at what we're
doing we're getting promoted we're
making more money so this young man uh
the thoughts are hey go ahead and start
the YouTube of the podcast but let's
also get very serious about the type of
work that makes you feel fulfilled and
that you're actually good at and now we
do both and if the podcast and the
YouTube channel takes off
fantastic you can check out but until
then uh we don't want to just stay in
the social services field either because
again it's not long before you're
languishing in a role that is very
needed oh yeah I mean you're on the
front lines with with people and if
you're not committed to Social Service
work you shouldn't be doing it so well
it's so funny that our brains can
they're like either I have to be
miserable and make good money or I'm
gonna love what I do and be broke that's
right why do our brains just give us
those two options when we know there's
so much more in between well because I
think again the the way work is
described to us the way we experience
work so many times is in a negative
light you know so it's kind of like all
right boy if I want to do something I
love there ain't no way I can make money
doing that like the dream job is like a
fantasy it's like a unicorn with wings
do all unicorns have wings or is that
just the ones in my head do okay very
good thank you well and look at this
story Ken he said I despise the fact
that I went to college I lack the
self-confidence the parents pressured
him into getting a degree he didn't want
to get in the field he didn't want to be
in yeah and then parents are like why
don't you have the kids yet in the house
and they're like I'm miserable yeah Mom
and Dad yeah you you pressured me down a
path that I didn't want to go to hell
great oh and also what's the podcast
idea and go if it's sports for example
well maybe you should go work in sports
oh that's exactly because YouTube is not
a that's a very good call out so when
you say I want to be a YouTuber that
tells me nothing that's just what's a
professional role that is in some way
related to the subject of the podcast
that'll be something there's got to be
something I mean I want to start a
sports podcast with you do you yeah it's
called SEC what I did there SCC what I
did your greatest sports commentating I
know nothing I know nothing about it I
don't even know how that would work well
I'm learning along the way and maybe I
teach you a a play or two a play okay a
play action pass if you will I don't
know George I'm afraid you're gonna hurt
yourself so that's a free idea if
anybody wants to start a new sport let's
let's get to some money work and
relationship questions to keep you away
from Sports okay that's a touchdown I'll
tell you what would be fun is I'm going
to ask George during the commercial
break if he knows what the SEC stands
for good chance he doesn't I'll report
to you when we come back for our final
segment but first Mike is on the line in
Sarasota Florida Mike how can we help
hey I appreciate it yeah just quick
question you know I'm um I'm basically
under contract uh you know of course I
could get out of it to buy a new home uh
actually it's a townhouse in Sarasota
and uh I guess the the question is uh
you know I have some debt you know as
far as uh student loans um but basically
to kind of give you a snapshot
um uh you know I make you know around 90
000 a year and I have about 84 000 of
student loans uh I'm 46. uh I have you
know a car payment but other than that
that's the only debts I have and the
mortgage payment looks like it's going
to be around the 2900 with you know all
fees and everything cdds HOA fees
Etc 2900 to 3100 and uh I'm just
wondering if if it's something that I
should do or just continue the rents and
see what the market does in the next
couple years uh and I will say I have
about uh in maybe 38 000 my 401k
okay well the short answer here Mike is
no I would not do this because I'm
scared you're going to be house poor and
you're going to be stressed up to your
eyeballs and this American dream of home
ownership is going to quickly become a
nightmare
that's what I'm feeling I feel in your
voice you kind of are sensing is going
there uh what is your take-home pay
yeah I was going to say unfortunately a
lot of taxes you know I'm I'm in sales
so you know I get a salary in
commissions but to give you an example
you know last year I made 105 this year
maybe it's 85 and the next year could be
a hundred you know what I mean so it
fluctuates and I get taxed you know kind
of heavily is your take home generally
the five or six a month
um
I think that's fair yeah to be
conservative maybe 47 4800 after and you
know deductions for health insurance and
you're talking 3 100 is going to be
going towards this home ownership dream
and so man that is 63 of your take-home
pay is being swallowed up immediately so
I would get out of this contract if you
can do it with no harm and no foul and
with your integrity intact but you're
just you know it's it's an FHA or I'm
sorry I didn't mean to cut you no it's
all right an FHA loan and there is some
dirty big incentives they put on it you
know it's a it's supposedly like for
about 420 000 and then you know they
lower the price by 30 something thousand
and they're paying pretty much most of
my closing costs so there are some
pretty good deals but at the end of the
day I'm looking at the payment last
thing I want is to be houseport and I
and I also kind of Wonder the second
part of that question should I just
focus on paying off those student loans
over the next few years and then try to
buy something yes I want you out of debt
completely before you even start saving
up for the downtown payment before you
do that you need an emergency fund on
top of that so here's the deal baby step
one thousand dollars baby step two pay
off all Consumer Debt using the debt
snowball line up all your debts smallest
to largest and attack the small one
aggressively make minimum payments on
the rest baby step three three to six
months of expenses in the emergency fund
and then we start saving up for the down
payment but these FHA Loans are not a
blessing it's not a deal because they
just make broke people even broker
because they can get into homes with
nothing down while still having a
hundred grand of debt sitting on the
other side so man I want the best for
you Mike I know that you want this dream
your 46 you're going I should be a
homeowner by now but when you do it
slowly with patience with no debt and
you get the down payment saved it's
going to be a completely different
experience so be patient stay the course
and get out of this deal
good stuff there George all right you
gotta take a quick break but we're not
going anywhere and you shouldn't either
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by
my colleague George Campbell and we're
here for you this hour our scripture of
the day comes from Joshua 1 verse 9.
have I not commanded you be strong and
courageous do not be frightened and do
not be dismayed for the Lord your God is
with you wherever you go today's quote
from Elon Musk haven't heard of him much
hasn't been in the news much no not at
all it's been real All Quiet on the
Western Front there yeah by the way
fantastic movie on Netflix I was baiting
you into that Canon I know I can't even
help myself is folks ADHD is real uh I
want you to know the struggle is real to
stay focused uh today's quote from Elon
Musk when something is important enough
you do it even if the odds are not in
your favor boy now that begs a question
George they plant the this is
development okay the the Scuttle butt
the the
brouhaha is that Twitter is going down
what say you George I mean it's been
real interesting to watch this
elon's favor I don't know I mean I don't
want to bet against the guy because
Against All Odds he's been very
successful but the way things are going
over at Twitter
I mean it was trending yesterday R.I.P
Twitter and uh so a lot of people laid
off a lot of people left yesterday
because there was a there was a deadline
now this is relevant to remote work
there was a deadline as of yesterday if
you were going to want to remote work
you were done he was going to give you
three months and the ultimatum of you're
about to be working real intense hours
and if that's not for you well let me
know by 5 PM because you're gone and so
then he changed it so then he came out
and tweeted and he was like all right on
remote work if you can get an agreement
with your leader so he Elon is not uh
the picture of stability as a leader I'm
just saying that's a nice way to put it
all right very good uh Scranton PA boy I
love when we go to Scranton uh always
puts a smile on my face Uh Kevin joins
us in Scranton Pennsylvania Kevin how
can we help
hi it's nice to talk to you guys good to
talk to you sir what's going on
um so I was just curious if I should
just pause my investments and start
paying all my student loans
um I I graduate in the spring
of this year so I didn't know uh what
should I do about the uh about that
okay how many uh how much do you have in
student loans
I um well I didn't really realize it I'm
the first in my uh family to actually
kind of go through college
so um I'm about 29 years old so when I
went I kind of thought it was just like
they were just telling me it's free
money don't worry about it who told you
I realized that I ended up owing 40 000
in student loans
oh boy so um you thought they were just
giving away forty thousand dollars worth
of money no they they were telling no
they were telling me like uh it was like
pelligrants and it's free money oh okay
like the financial aid package they're
like well it includes 40 000 and
subsidized loans and I didn't know about
that okay well we we learned from our
mistakes and I fell into the same traps
as you Kevin so I'm not beating you up
here but uh there is a time and place
that I want you to invest that is going
to help you build wealth and that is
once you're debt free and so as long as
you have debt in your life I want you to
pause all investing and not because
George said but because we found that if
you want to build wealth long term you
get out of debt stay out of debt which
gives you the margin to invest way more
later on
oh okay so um you don't have an income
right now
uh yeah I make about like twenty five
thousand dollars a year okay
so um I have a um about like six grand
and some stocks
um I was thinking about cashing that out
and just either holding on to it as a as
a um emergency fund
do you have any other money in the bank
yeah I have about two two thousand in my
bank account okay keep the 2000 there I
would cash out of those stocks and apply
it to your student loan debt and start
to knock those out
that is your your next goal in life is
to get rid of this do you have any other
debt other than the student loans car
payments credit cards
maybe about like 300 on a credit card
but I'm about to pay that off and get
rid of it love it yeah Cut That Thing Up
close the account never look back I'm
gonna gift you a Kevin Financial Peace
University because it'll walk you
through what we call the baby steps and
in there it's going to show you exactly
how to get out of debt the best way the
fastest way which is the debt snowball
listing all your debts smallest to
largest regardless of the interest rate
and then you're never going to look back
but man I want I see a bright future for
a guy like you and when you get out of
school and you're trying to do investing
you're trying to pay off the loans
you're trying to save up for the down
payment you end up nowhere because
you're doing 48 things at once so slow
down get real focused and intense on one
thing at a time that's what we teach in
Financial Peace University so hang on
the line Austin will pick up and we'll
get that to you yeah love that love love
the young people thinking about this
stuff and being serious about great
stuff let's go to Caleb in Boise Idaho
Caleb how can we help
hi
um so I I think I have a career question
um I'm trying to figure out if I need to
um switch my job or add another job for
more income because I'm 22 years old
um and I'm still living at home and me
and my girlfriend are getting pretty
serious and we'd like to kind of get
married hopefully next year or something
like that but I don't have any money
saved up for a ring or an apartment or
anything like that okay what are you
doing now
uh I actually I actually love my job
um I I get to work on exotic cars and
and stuff like that and wash them and
detail I'm a detailer okay but it
doesn't it's not pain the most right now
like it's it's kind of just getting you
by or maybe I'm just not budgeting well
what are you making per hour
I'm making 17 an hour okay and uh give
me the fine and so do you have any debt
uh you were telling I don't think you do
do you have any debt
um I have a a car payment I still owe 16
on oh and then maybe
uh a 400 uh car repair Bill coming in
but all right so what's your car payment
uh 321 a month all right so you said you
thought it was a career question or
what's the specific question about your
work
yeah basically I'm just getting really
overwhelmed and stressed because like
um I really want to get married I really
want to move out but I I'm just kind of
living paycheck to paycheck and
um I my car has been having so many
issues it's just like a constant there's
always something wrong with it yeah so
I'm I'm debating if I should get a truck
I'm looking at like a 17 000 truck
but I feel like that might be too much
yeah and well first of all all right so
you need more income because it feels
like you like working with cars do you
want to work long term with cars
is that is that I think I do yeah okay
yeah so I tell you what I think this is
less about changing the job unless you
can get a better paying job yeah are you
working for a company doing detailing or
is this on your own yeah yeah it's a
really big company it's it's a yeah it's
a higher end all right so here's my
point I think your options are can I
keep working with this company but get a
better paying job with the company still
working with cars okay or you need to go
get another job which is a part-time job
you're young
and you can go work and get another job
maybe making 20 bucks an hour stocking
shelves at a big box store you know go
get more income and then we only got
about a minute and a half but I want to
have George step in here because the
reason you're living paycheck to
paycheck is really not the 17 an hour
job it's because you're not managing
your money well and George can help you
there yeah so what's this car worth
uh well it I bought it at 21 and I could
probably sell it like on Facebook for
17. it's a it's a Mustang so it's kind
of hard to sell right now why is it hard
to sell right now
uh just because Mustangs are harder to
sell like sports cars are harder to sell
yeah I think it's water there's a guy
like you out there who wants to buy a
Mustang for 17 grand so uh I think you
go sell that Mustang and get a reliable
used cheaper car maybe for six or ten
Grand to help speed up this journey and
free you from that car payment
um do you have any money in the bank
thousand dollars okay I'm kind of on
step two I just purchased uh the
financial piece oh great good well
that'll be very helpful as well but I'll
tell you this I met a kid 16 years old
at our Building Wealth event in
Sacramento he was making forty to
seventy dollars an hour doing detailing
on his own
and so I say that to say you may want to
go out on your own and just go in your
neighborhood Facebook group and next
door and start posting in there and
saying hey I do details for 120 bucks
and you start to get a lot of gigs you
do a reliable job and you start to make
double your income overnight just doing
even on the side right now you could do
that on the weekends
so I should just really kind of find
some side income to kind of for now long
term we got to get the income up but for
now things you can do tomorrow is go do
this stuff on the side while you're
looking for what does the latter look
like for me to grow in this company or
somewhere else working in cars or
working with cars but that can be
figured out long term once we stop the
fire hey thank you so much for the call
Caleb good job George thanks I want to
say thanks to the guys behind the glass
for keeping us on the air and we want to
thank you America for listening and
watching this is your show it is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]